hey guys it's really bright today and I
forgot my sunglasses
unfortunately thankfully it's a nice day
in New York I've been here for almost a
week doing lots of fun things and today
on the agenda is going to the Nintendo
store going to the Lego store and I'm
not sure what else we're gonna do but
I'm going to tweet and we're going to
see what kind of suggestions you guys
give me today we're shooting in 60
frames a second goal
so Nintendo's
did I win this game
there is a big gold Mario amiibo right
behind me
it looks really nice way more what these
are too big to carry home with me money
order
you watch you
this is the problem because I want every
single animal
it's Maddy it's basically Maddy the
dj'ing dog basically has already existed
in Animal Crossing any night I was
this is thought I needed my house these
light of containers for all of my evil
look
I can adjust look here
they designed this everything that I had
money
so
you
the Gamecube basically this is why I
almost failed college because when Mario
came out for gamecube that is all we did
for an entire week and I think when
structures thought that I died
yes I have
i sat down cake a slider upstairs and
then he disappeared I turned around he
was gone so I got to think of another
one the gonna be Maddie's new toy I
can't wait to give Maddie's new toy it's
basically his future self as a DJ
do you have the minifigure of yourself
no yes I do
let's see we can find adjustment figure
hey you gotta find all the pieces these
are outfits so not happy with the
selections here so I'm gonna have to
craft one from pieces that I have at
home in the internet because this is
just as a yo what's not me right there
no take me apart yeah okay we yeah kind
of where's your teacher done he's in my
backpack that's probably not my favorite
Lego store that I ever made a little
small
they also do not have many selections
from the minifigure to create your own
so your app will okay I'll work on it
that's my project
Microsoft Store and then after that
really the Apple store we already went
to the Samsung store so I don't even
know what
have you guys heard of that
keep your world safe your worlds are
backed up on your gameband and are
secure cloud-based servers
play minecraft anywhere what is this
what are you is this what I'm gonna need
to be are
this is crazy
applesauce
I'm not going in because honestly I've
been here so many times but I don't need
anything but we can look on the outside
so I feel like I'm in an episode of Law
& Order right now and I'm about to just
walk upon a dead body that accurate it
happened maybe this is an episode right
now I'm vlogging and you know I turned
my camera and I happen to catch like a
murder or something happening and then
I'm a part of the investigation and they
subpoena my camera I have to go to court
I have to testify that I I saw the
murderer like there's a body over there
I can't zoom anymore so you guys are
gonna have to believe it just that
there's a seam here
they have yeah if you want to know what
they look like you can go thank you
because I have an excellent juggler but
horrible mathematician
two hours
five months early
makes me so sad seeing all these verses
just like tied up crapping in a little
bag and then like force to give people
rides around the city in the middle of
crazy traffic I hate it I hate it
joining the Starbucks in New York I
haven't seen one in a long time going
found one right
my god I want to put my snap up there
all right
it disappeared find some dogs to fill an
intern
all right
I'm scared okay well sorry Express we
tried that you too huh what
oh the Star Wars exhibit and there is a
cupcake
surprise
I didn't think bb-8 was gonna be here
I definitely need that I also need this
a cookie
Star Wars cookbook
oh this is by far the best advertising
I've ever seen snapchat I'm not even
doing I'm not joking I think it's
amazing what else do you out of sight
the little pigeons just having a little
meal hi
so I'm late like always I spend I hope
you're not gonna fall
I spent most of my day trying to figure
out where I'm gonna set my camera to
vlog I also spend the second my day
being late for everything it's finally a
nice day in New York the first part of
this trip it rained almost the entire
time and I'm not gonna lie much as I
love traveling I'm getting sick of this
hotel I think I need a bigger bag we've
already established that I don't know
where my wallet is not there hmm via
Starbucks but I'm late
I feel got charged everything is not
awesome right now dead where's my wallet
where's my wallet sitting right here on
the bed all right we can go now forgot
the called over let's go pick up
location request
come get me buddy I should probably some
chapstick cool I think we're actually
ready now
sounds like this will place is falling
apart goddess lighting is
all right Jimmy it's Wall Street we're
heading to daily dot we're going to do
up on little 10 year YouTube anniversary
video so I'm excited for you guys
I was trying but it wasn't working I was
like god these revolving doors uh only
time I'm not stopping in these new
treats they have they have meatballs
with tomato sauce and chicken skewers
and bacon-wrapped dates
joke they have trouble and makkac with
their beer here and why is this struggle
to wine
oh shoot home
wait a minute
books it has why
this is like the future breakfast this
is like the best Starbucks I've ever
seen in my entire life where are we we
are in financial district
Lina yeah we're so macho I'm the best
time I'm sorry can you say nice didn't
cause it's our safe
hi I'm meeting some candy and packing
and listening to Radiohead things are
going great if you've seen this on
Twitter especially with a bunch of the
roosterteeth guys long story it's 5 a.m.
right now and I'm going to a shoot it's
a really good look I called this morning
let's take you and put you in the bag
now finally got my sunrise shot cuz the
drone shot definitely didn't work the
other day it's time to go
it's 541 cars here 545 off to a really
fun shoot
thankfully I'll be doing my hair makeup
there because this is not acceptable I'm
not going to miss this elevator at all
we made it to the airport so thankfully
liable gordias crazy because the
terminals aren't where they should be or
something I'm not sure but I ended up on
a bus and I'm not sure how I actually
managed to make it here because of the
other people that were on the shuttle
bus definitely missed their flight but
we're here in the terminal and they've
got this incredible little pulse it's an
iPad and you can order your food
directly from it and that's it I don't
have to talk to any people I'm trying to
figure out what I'm gonna order I kind
of want the chicken fingers but they're
under the children's menu okay I'll just
see you across and it's here it's
arrived god I'm so tired
forensic expertise CFC 14 Bernie Marco
quite a hole okay I'm just gonna end
this video because I don't feel like
vlogging anymore and I don't I think I
slept maybe like two hours last night so
I'm not able to fire is that sure so
I'll see you guys in Pittsburgh which is
where I'm going
we've got a list of things here's a list
of things check one off the list we got
a card we've been here for three hours
we haven't done anything we got - I got
a new iPhone okay I need to get a bra
for these these luscious lovely lady
should you check this off the list
try shampoo and bronzer check headphones
check where Jamie go Jamie why'd you go
freeze would that be more of a Brian
wedding present and brew very upset
Brian never heard never heard of him
Jenna got her camera out at the same
time I bought them with my money
did you guys even recognize me wait um
what's really yeah you guys I was like
oh uh go grab my item
all the things are now checked off our
list now we're gonna go to JB's yes I'm
all this is my mall fly South Hills Mall
self is renovacell Ajmal assignment mall
that's a new sign
oh we're gonna get some good shots today
baby
oh that's gonna be great
I don't have my cable you film a little
with this this would be great we're
gonna get a great sunset I got to hurry
up I gotta get this drone out there dad
so I told my dad I'm gonna fly this
thing until it tells me to stop he's not
too excited about it
just as the sunrise dogs to show warming
up the motorway you know you felt this
way before
I can't recall a time day don't know in
flight this is my part of something
greater and when you get up this raging
do
I let it go for all time say I let you
stay
when everywhere
and brain always
don't know if like this is my son
seems to work
so the
no mystery
the ball
stick gum
like two hours before
do you ever love
did you see how fast that book